I'd like to welcome all of you here
today for this wonderful lunch but more
importantly and those of you who have
been through the program this morning
have told me how productive this day has
been to the first columbia alumni
leaders meeting in prior years this was
a meeting of the columbia alumni
association assembly and as good and
productive as that was we decided to
expand the program and the constituency
this weekend to include alumni leaders
from the college and general studies
engineering the Graduate School of Arts
and Sciences and journalism so that you
could come yourselves and have your own
leadership meetings and join with the
broader CAA leadership in a way that
would bring us all together to share
ideas to share best practices to
reconnect with Columbia and with one
another and that's really what the CAA
is all about it's a simple idea but one
I think that is extraordinarily powerful
and the turnout this afternoon I think
underscores this potential now within
this university wide meeting of the
minds we have a little bit of business
to do and at CAA business with respect
to elected the new chair and this year's
board of the columbia alumni association
and let me take a moment to explain just
a bit this process so you understand its
inclusiveness its transparency and its
representative nature the CIA board is
made up of 40 alums drawing from across
the university from every one of its 16
schools from a wide range of graduating
years and professional interests and
personal ethnic and demographic
backgrounds including representation
from alumni leaders around the world a
nominating committee of that board of
your board puts together a slate of
officers for each year the nominating
committee is made up of about 10 of our
most senior members and we have the
election conducted really in two steps
one is a large participation by proxy if
you're going to have an alumni assembly
which is made up of about a hundred and
fifty or 180 people that are drawn from
across the city the nation and the world
they obviously can't all be here today
so we have met our quorum to meet by the
proxies that we have received that I
have received in conjunction with Donna
McPhee our vice president for alumni
affairs these were sent out via email
and have been returned and we have a
quorum obviously then to meet in
addition to the Assembly members who are
here today and those individuals through
proxy have also cast their ballots for
the slate the second part of the
election is to ask those members here
present who have not voted by proxy to
raise their hands when I asked them to
to vote on the slate so let me talk for
a moment about a slate it's been my
privilege after having served two years
as vice chair of the CAA under steve
cases wonderful chairmanship to have
served as your chair for the past four
years and in my place has been nominated
george van amson a college graduate a
leader on the Columbia community in
every context you can imagine a trustee
emeritus one of the founding members of
the black alumni council a leader in the
college and George has been the vice
chair of the CAA essentially sends it
since its founding has served as
chair of our honors and prizes committee
and I cannot think and I assure you the
nominating committee and with the full
endorsement of the board could not think
of a more perfect candidate to serve as
chair standing for re-election is Brian
Chris Berg our current vice chair brian
is a former president of the College
Alumni Association and again is very
heavily involved in leadership at the
college at the University in the CAA and
in fact serves as the program chair for
this weekend's activities also nominated
are Armand Adams 06 the college
representative from the black alumni
council here at terani Barry president
of the Columbia College Alumni
Association Stephen Cain college and law
president of the Columbia University
Club of New England avanti moose mu
lusti president of the Columbia club of
India Philippa Portnoy bar nerd and
business a elected member at large rocks
and Smithers college and law president
of the Columbia club of atlanta kyriakos
tsk opolis the college a university
trustee and adrianna villavicencio from
the Latino Alumni Association at this
time I according to the bylaws of the
Association ask if there are any other
nominations there is a provision in the
by laws by which other nominations can
be put forward with the signatures of 25
alums thus far I have not received any
other nominations but it is proper for
me at this juncture to ask if there are
any other thank you when I'm not certain
it's not in the script what I do if
I think we just adjourned so for those
of you who are voting members of the
assembly if I could ask for a show of
hands in favor of the slate that i have
read i would appreciate it thank you
very much clearly joined with the
proxies we have received it is an
overwhelming endorsement of our new
leadership and thankfully the election
went as I might have anticipated because
we're going to show a video now and and
George's in it so it's particularly
convenient that this is all going
according to plan the video was created
by Joe Turner Lynn a graduate of both
the college and the school of arts and i
welcome you to watch the video while you
enjoy your lunch thank you very much